hello guys I'm Greg back at it again
nine Monnet also back at it
Monnet is here with me today to watch
some videos for the richest one of my
favorite YouTube channels
I love celebrity news I love celebrity
gossip a lot of people don't think that
I'm really into that not true
this whole Johnny Depp Amber Heard
situation I'm on top of that [ __ ]
heartbreaking heartbreaking yes
entertaining most definitely I'm gonna
watch with monnet right now ten actors
who had to get drunk to shoot their
movie I've had to get high to shoot
scenes before I've never gotten drunk
filth I can't operate yeah I don't think
that would end well for anything
yeah have you ever had to get drunk to
shoot something no I don't think I'd
want you to bring an authentic
performance to life yet can't unless
these are like sex scenes or something
that I get like actors can get
uncomfortable with like Margot Robbie
and the wolf of Wall Street
oh god you mustn't think that she must
been drunk that whole fund of my naked
other than having sex
alcohol many of us turn to it throughout
our lives to make things a little more
fun or a little more variability so the
answer to life isn't in a bottle for
some people things seem to go a little
bit always when they have some liquid
courage by their side always is no more
evident than in the world of acting
shouldn't really drink on the job
okay why are they showing okay so this
is the first one released in 1998 the
movie Wild Things is generally
considered by critics to be a pretty bad
mood I didn't really care because the
film featured some steamy cool makeup
yeah
a 7-game brush on methods there was
another uncredited cast member helping
them get through these scenes alcohol
okay not surprised yes
in the 2003 film Bad Santa Thoren plays
a conman who aims to rob stores on
Christmas Eve his character looks dirty
Haggard and in many scenes of drunk yeah
good acting and makeup that made this
possible
partly and in other words the
american-born actor admitted that he got
completely into character by being more
than sort of trouble to do okay
Apocalypse Now is considered a classic
of the big screen full of big-name stars
the movie was almost a complete train
wreck but that's another story
he is it full of iconic and memorable
scenes including the introductory
montage to Martin Sheen's character
Captain Benjamin Davis can see that Jean
was quite drunk during this shoe and the
director just let the cameras roll while
he moved about the room the street
elements punching the mirror I'm cutting
up his hand we're all real Wow fueled by
a considerable amount of alcohol Wow
Fred Astaire what when it comes to
legends of the big screen especially
those with a knack for dancing there is
no one bigger than Fred Astaire you'd
figure all those intricate dance and
coordination require a stone silver
apparently not in the 1942 classic
holiday in Astaire reportedly did a
number of shots during a shoot for the
aptly named drunk dance scene after
several takes the legend had reportedly
consumed several drinks of bourbon could
ever dream of being true black swan'
mysterious an apparently deadly
competitive world of ballet dancing that
pretty much sums up the 2010 film black
swan religion Ethel sex scene between
Mila Kunis and Natalie Portman as
lesbian scenes ever shot some people
were left wondering how the actors were
able to do it
rumors have it that a little tequila
helped to remove any nerves Kennison
Portman deny this but there are
witnesses who were on set that's where a
little alcohol helps calm everybody down
what being an actor can see you take on
some very challenging roles but it also
has a fair share of downtime as you sit
and wait for your next scenes go by a
little sooner but also for making long
stretches of waiting around a little
more bearable while shooting the hunger
games catching fire
JLo would pastime by downing pina
coladas in her trailer she didn't get
drunk in the process probably does not
jump to mind straight away no no these
would be enough to make anyone dream
Andrews turned to the bottle for a
different reason
in 1965 s The Sound of Music apparently
she had a great deal of trouble trying
to sing and play instruments at the same
time to help out she turned to schnapps
to relax and successfully perform the
scene for doremi no way Wow what she is
so happy been in the news for all the
wrong reasons and
here is more than a little statement so
you can't say that Shia LaBeouf doesn't
get it how can you film yeah nine year
old played a bootlegger involved in the
moonshine trade to fit the role LaBeouf
made sure he got rip-roaring drunk off
moonshine committed acting more than a
few people think it was just a
convenient excuse to get drunk yeah when
you're in a movie titled drinking
buddies you have to figure alcohol is in
some way involved they didn't quite
understand just how much beer would be
involved since the film is based around
a craft brewery what better way to
immerse yourself in that than the world
of beer in fact Anna Kendrick told
reporters that in the scene where she's
playing cards every time she lost and
had to drink the beverage was actual
beer needless to say by the end of the
shoot she was actually in drunk there it
is drugs money even the F word is
dropped a record number of times in such
a movie you naturally expect a racy sex
scene or two and you'd be right bill
sees the to engage in notable sexy that
required a little preparation in
preparation for the scene Robby was more
than a little nervous to make sure she
was ready for when director Martin
Scorsese yelled action for 25 year-old
down three shots of tequila we figure it
must have worked I was good scene 23
hope you enjoyed this boozy video let us
know what you thought about it in the
country sausage did you know she's only
25 years old and subscribe to the rig
when she did that oh wow why yeah she's
small - she's like five - really yeah oh
man I think she's gorgeous
she's beautiful I think she is an angel
I think she's magical I think she is God
okay did you ever see the movie wild
things no I have it
well the yeah there's this pretty racy
scene where they're like making out
pool and doing some lesbian stuff I
think you see Kevin Bacon's penis in the
film - what yeah yeah see Kevin's bacon
you know what I mean - girls fried bacon
Wow
I don't think that movie has any plot -
yeah I think it's - girls is partying
like Craig's have a big crush on the F
Campbell growing up was beyond that you
know I saw her and the movie scream and
I used to watch scream every Sunday
after church when I was really young and
Neve Campbell was you know I always felt
like she was really in danger you know
and I hadn't really cared about her she
was so pretty but innocent you know like
she's going to use horrible thing my
heart is warm always works well now I'm
gonna watch the movie yeah it's
fantastic Billy Bob Thornton on Bad
Santa not surprising it Oh looked wasted
the entire movie I think when you play a
drunk guy and then you use like getting
drunk to get any character I think
that's just an excuse like like if I
have to play a STONER and I smoke read
again a character I know just being
excused for me to smoke weed because I'm
playing a stunt you know what I mean I
feel like that's kind of what you did
here yeah I think it would be harder and
more impressive to play that drunk yeah
yeah Billy Bob come on dude it's like
when Johnny Depp was Jack Sparrow he
wasn't drunk though well I don't know
knowing all that situation with Amber
Heard he might have been might have been
she found out he was that's why that's
why she's she didn't like pirates
anymore yeah an apocalypse now I
remember that opening with Martin Sheen
like losing his [ __ ] I thought that was
like some great acting I didn't realize
he was actually completely drunk I was
like man this guy's very vulnerable how
you let yourself go like that I'm from
the camera and liquid courage huh good
courage I like that I like that term
liquid courage I'm telling you man if
you drink everyday you just be way
happier yeah that's I like sometimes I
drink in the morning sometimes afternoon
sometimes all three times of the day
yeah it's like it's like my problems
just go away
every year at me every European in there
every other American father wait wait
wait
are you a French stair fan I do love
reticent yeah no this makes it so much
better yeah cuz now anytime you see him
Dan have you seen him dance
no he's incredible and he's so
entertaining he's always so into what
he's doing and the fact that he gets
wasted during all of it
well you loosen up you know I'm an
amazing dancer when I'm drunk nothing to
answer I will have to see that oh yeah
no trust me I can I can boogie see it's
all about the hips right here it's all
about the hips going out you can't deal
when you're sitting like a lap dance on
the torso this is my snake Medusa girls
let's see what Natalie Portman and Mila
Kunis is no surprise I mean that's good
for you're bisexual I personally am NOT
okay but I could understand how you
would be nervous to do that let alone in
front of I don't know how many people on
set yeah watching you do that take over
and over and over again would you ever
do makeout scene with another girl a
make-out scene for within a movie like
Black Swan probably okay yeah cuz of the
movie yeah I mean not not just like in a
bedroom okay well that's good that's
good yeah I could do a make-out scene
with a guy depending on how funny the
movie is wouldn't do it for a dramatic
role noble even doing Brokeback
mountains nothing nothing I'm I think
I'm talking about like there's this
movie that came out when I was really
young called in announced our name Kevin
Kline this guy thought he was gay it's
funny [ __ ] dude gay rules for comedy
Jennifer Lawrence on the set of The
Hunger Games kind of sad looks like a
huge [ __ ] blockbuster she's like I'm
just bored on say
regardless I love her yeah I think she's
a great actress
and I love her in interviews Julie
Andrews oh man those kids must have have
I bet she was a raging alcoholic onset
raging [ __ ] alcoholic it's
funny how you can be so graceful in them
under the influence I bet she beat those
kids every day oh no she'd walk around
with a bat with barbed wire
Shia LaBeouf man oh oh yeah another dude
being like yeah I got drew yeah whatever
we know you have drinking problems
you and your DUIs happy shy even Stevens
was never watch that show never seen a
single episode actually ah well look at
the time I should whoa you've never seen
even Stevens no I have seen Eagle Eye
and Disturbia oh and I saw his penis in
that one movie where he showed his penis
and that music video where he showed his
penis what why what music video the SIA
one I think so yeah I didn't see that
whatever
I love Shia LaBeouf he's great no he's a
really good actor sometimes he seems
like he's acting to me but most of the
time I think he's fantastic
and a Kendrick I mean she's she seems
like that girl that you can marry you
know yeah she's like hot in her own way
but she's more like oh I would take you
home to my mom and have her disapprove
of you but then work to get her approval
of you then she realizes my mom it's
like you know just so insecure she
doesn't want let me go to another woman
then she lets Anna Kendrick you know
take my soul away we have kids together
mom takes care of the children Mama's
little nuts
kidnap two kids you thought about this
before and I margot robbie scene yeah
yeah yeah yeah I figured that that out
of all scenes must have been like for
sure I could see why that's number one
on this list yeah because that is all
her like
yeah like these other scenes are usually
like partners involved you know and this
first bigger film yeah yeah like
Scorsese behind the camera and DiCaprio
looking at your crotch like that's not
big the pressure is ah ah sure is on
last time DiCaprio look at my crotch
turn into a vagina
anyway Jews and Christians and Muslims
and whatever sex you are if you're new
to the channel subscribe today become a
reject would you not please do that
please monette Moyo has a sweet eats
YouTube channel I do you better you go
on that channel because I have me a
recent guest appearance on that this is
a fun time you should check it out her
partner Jess was really into me you hear
that personal trainer boyfriend that I
am follow us on our Instagram and
Twitter